bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du journal voilà ce que l'on
peut retenir en ce vendredi 5 juin une
exposition fait sensation ce moment au
château de versailles anish kapoor
propose du 9 juin au 1er novembre
ses oeuvres monumentales une vision
qu'il veut politique à l'occasion du
tricentenaire de la mort de louis xiv à
la maison de l'environnement à magny les
hameaux à 10 ans elle a été inaugurée
jour pour jour à 5 juin la structure
devrait disparaître les associations se
mobilisent une manifestation est prévue
ce vendredi soir un médiateur de
l'enseignement pour la ville de plaisir
la convention vient d'être renouvelé le
médiateur intervient auprès des familles
dans les écoles et collèges du quartier
du val hibou et puis dans quelques
instants avec mon invité nous parlerons
du festival alternatiba qui a lieu
samedi et dimanche à la verrière et donc
halliche cap ours d'abord à versailles
l inauguration officielle s'est déroulée
ce vendredi matin en présence de
l'artiste plasticien de 61 ans
originaire de bombay six oeuvres
exposées en grande partie dans les
jardins parmi lequel ce vortex baptisé
des sanctions ou encore cette corne
d'abondance sur le tapis vert du nom de
dirty corner mais déjà surnommé par ses
détracteurs qui ont beaucoup
d'imagination le vagin de l'arène car
cette nouvelle exposition a fait
polémique
elle divise anish kapoor l'assurent il a
voulu bouleverser les équilibres dans
les jardins de le nôtre tout en
préservant l'intégrité physique du lieu
inutile donc pour l'artiste selon
l'artiste de chercher uniquement des
connotations sexuelles
on l'écouté vous ne pouvez pas voir ça
uniquement de cette façon vous ne pouvez
pas être sérieux avec cette question
voir cette oeuvre uniquement de cette
manière ne fait aucun bien histoire au
travail que j'ai fait l'argument
politique est un argument assez ridicule
faut faire attention avec les
interprétations à sens unique
ça ne mène nulle part je comprends qu'il
y ait des polémiques sur l'art
contemporain à versailles à elles ont
toujours eu lieu
je crois même qu'elle avait lieu
probablement si on retrouvait les écrits
de l'époque
du temps de louis xiv parce qu'on était
d'accord ou pas avec un artiste je pense
que donc c'est normal que le débat
existe sur la présence de l'art
contemporain à versailles mais je pense
que certaines polémiques sont inutiles
voire accessible et puis un pardon ainsi
un reportage complet à retrouver dans
notre édition de lundi à des propos
recueillis par vous le fait de richier
patrick jacques de dixmude justement
l'art contemporain at il sa place au
château de versailles c'est la question
que nous sommes allez vous poser
aujourd'hui même dans les rues de la
commune
versailles c'est ça reste quand même
notre patrimoine et rajouter rajouter
deux des choses assez nouvelle jeu
parce que ça ferait tâche dans le décor
mais plutôt classique voilà l'art
moderne ne boude pas trop surtout dans
les manifestations au château de
versailles
je trouve ça d'une odeur épouvantable
moi j'ai jeûné d'obstruction contre
aucun art tant qu'ils n'abîment pas ce
qu'il y a sur place c'est pourquoi pas
pourquoi ne sais pas pourquoi pas une
certaine ouverture mais rien de choquant
dans le parc du château ça me gêne pas
trop mais je me souviens d'une
exposition où c'était dans les salles il
y avait des choses qui se trouvait était
un peu moi qui moi me heurter la
sensibilité
j'aime beaucoup ces expositions
éphémères parce que
bien ça met un peu de nouveauté un peu
de distraction c'est très agréable
devoir de visiter le château et de
devoirs à toutes ces oeuvres
contemporaines une information cinéma
pour continuer à nouveau multiplexe en
projet la commission départementale
d'équipement commercial vin vient de
valider le projet d'importation donc
d'un cinéma à coignières ce dernier
devait être installé en lieu et place de
la fabrique rue des arpents une ancienne
plateforme logistique de 18 m² inoccupé
depuis un an et demi
ce multiplex pourrait compter dix salles
d'une taille moyenne de 1230 fauteuil au
total et puis amour pas un autre projet
est aussi en cours huit salles et 1700
fauteuil dans la zone de paris ou alors
y at il trop de multiplexes qu une
équipe ex est ce que cela fait de
l'ombre au cinéma de quartier
c'est la question qui sera débattue dans
le 7 8 sociétés de mardi prochain en
direct à 18h30
émission présentée par nouradine agnan
le 5 par an le 5 juin 2005 la date est
symbolique était inaugurée la maison de
l'environnement à magna les hameaux est
dix ans plus tard la structure va fermer
en raison des baisses dotation versée
par la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines est la maison
la mission environnement est en
conserver revenant aux médiathèques un
collectif de soutien à la maison de
l'environnement vient de se créer une
pétition est en ligne depuis ce lundi
elle a recueilli 500 signatures et
symboliquement le collectif va se
retrouver ce vendredi soir devant la
maison de l'environnement 150 équipes de
trois personnes ont participé ce jeudi
soir au trophée des entreprises prémices
du défi nature qui aura lieu ce week-end
à l'île des loisirs sur place nickel et
demi d'euros et elodie moines
les sociétés étaient en compétition hier
sur l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines la 8e édition du trophée des
entreprises a réuni 150 équipes
proposées chacune trois membres et
compéter divisés en catégories hommes
femmes est mixte objectif de cet
événement sportif crée du lien social
dans le monde de l'entreprise
ça permet évidemment de créer du lien
entre les co rapporteurs une même
société de services différents en
général ce sont déjà des sportifs mais
pas que il ya beaucoup de gens qui
pratiquent non pas le sport pour la
première fois le sport de petites
compétitions pour la première fois à
travers à travers nouveaux raids et qui
leur permet effectivement de mieux
connaître qui leurs collègues du service
courrier qui leur cloud service
commercial qui leurs collègues du
technique
c'est également du lien entre les
collaborateurs de services différents
dans les entreprises de 50 ans de ville
et pas que puisque on a quand même
également beaucoup d'entreprises qui
viennent de l'ensemble des villes et la
région parisienne aujourd'hui la
compétition était divisé en plusieurs
épreuves course à pied vtt course
d'orientation et canoë sur la ligne
d'arrivée les 450 participants avaient
tous le sourire malgré quelques douleurs
dans les jambes difficile forcément
assez on s'attend pas à faire autant
d'efforts mais on est on est fier de
représenter le fond le vélodrome de la
nationale 51 en yvelines sur ce défi
nature
côté multi sports mais lui dit que c'est
pas très très long c'est accessible à
tout le monde c'est vraiment sympa c'est
très très dur
il fait super chaud débuts manqués les
collègues pour motiver mais lorsqu'on
fait bien
l'entreprise fight and de montigny le
bretonneux a remporté la victoire chez
les hommes et chez les femmes dans
l'épreuve mixte la mairie de trappes a
terminé à la première place
ils voulaient succès rencontré cette
année une neuvième édition est déjà
programmée pour l'année prochaine voilà
et puis si vous aimez le sport n'oubliez
pas le défi nature ces samedi et
dimanche à l'île des loisirs sains
trappe le ce samedi et ce dimanche
c'est également le festival alternative
à la verrière le festival de toutes les
alternatives et pour en parler tient de
charlotte da cunha bon soit il prend
soin de toi avec nous deux jours de
festival est-ce que vous pouvez nous
explique comment est née alternatiba
alterne l'abattoir avant la verrière oui
bien sûr yanis heures avant la verrière
alternatiba est né à bayonne en 2013
sous l'impulsion stéphane hessel qui a
voulu montrer qu'on pouvait beau
programme d indignez vous l'auteur
d'indignez-vous qui a voulu montrer
qu'on pouvait proposer des alternatives
positives au changement climatique et la
grande différence c'est qu'on ne veut
pas faire de l'environnement punitif
mais évidemment de montrer des
alternatives positives comment mieux
vivre dans notre société et par rapport
à l'environnement
alors ce week-end ça a lieu à la
verrière mais c'est aussi partout en
france et même en europe
c'est partout en france et en europe en
fait depuis ce lancement à bayonne on
voit des alternatives à être créé un
petit peu partout en france et en ile de
france et en europe notamment en
belgique et dans d'autres pays européens
on est le premier alternatiba ile de
france il y aura sud paris en octobre et
on a leur a aussi dans le sud yvelines
les rayons rambouillet en septembre
début juin
du côté du nord essonne donc alterner
bâti banner essonne début juin est le
nôtre qui est donc ce week-end et qui
qui va être un gros événement sur la
verrière mais qui est un événement pour
toute la communauté d'agglo évidemment
fait à quelques mois on est à quelques
mois de la 21e conférence sur le sur le
climat
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ce type
de festival s'est réveillé un peu les
consciences
oui on est sur du réveil de conscience
on est aussi sur le sur la démonstration
que la société civile est toujours
engagé c'est à dire qu'on a eu tendance
à oublier avec la crise notamment que
l'environnement était important que la
société civile que les citoyens que les
personnes lambda trouvait toujours ce
sujet important est de montrer que les
collectifs de citoyens et
est toujours là étaient motivés étaient
motivés pour organiser des gros
événements tous ensemble parce qu'elle
tint un climat est un collectif
d'associations du territoire et pourtant
quand on écoute les derniers sondages
les gens s'intéressent de moins en moins
à l'environnement ils sont assurément
plus préoccupés par les problèmes
d'emploi il incombe à utiliser c'est pas
incompatible en fait ce que nous on
cherche à prouver aussi c'est qu'on peut
vivre mieux avec moins d'argent et que
donc finalement s'intéresser à
l'environnement c'est aussi s'intéresser
à notre façon de vivre et et à notre
rapport à la consommation et qu'on peut
vivre mieux avec moins alors ce week-end
à la verrière vous attendez 5000
personnes oui il ya douze la même lutte
la douce thèmes qui ont été retenus
comme l'éducation l'économie donc les
transports l'énergie de l'habitat et
vous proposerai à la fois des
conférences des concerts mais aussi des
ateliers pour qu'en fait le citoyen
devienne acteur oui l'objectif c'est non
de me rendre le citoyen acteur sur tous
ces thèmes là on a aussi des tam
agriculture on a aussi un marché fermier
on est l'objectif est de prouver au
citoyen afin d'expliquer aux citoyens
des façons de mieux vivre de mieux vivre
au quotidien en consommant moins donc on
a des ateliers sur la production
d'énergie sur la démocratie aussi on a
un quartier démocratique qui montre
comment on peut être acteur de sa
citoyenneté en en d'éducation comme
comme vous l'avez expliqué sur des modes
de puériculture ou même d'éducation et
même surtout d'éducation alternative et
en agriculture durable effectivement qui
est quelque chose qui est mieux connue
le citoyen pourra se rendre compte
qu'ils peuvent à son niveau
faire des choses en étant un citoyen et
un consom'acteur et non pas un soc un
simple consommateur consom'acteurs mais
un consommateur qui paye adultes et
enfants aussi un il ya des enfants sont
les bienvenus alternatiba ya des choses
qui sont vraiment réservé pour les
enfants on a effectivement des choses
réservant pour les enfants on a un
atteint un quartier éducation qui ne
consacrer que aux enfants et à leurs
parents évidemment donc avec des
ateliers d'éducation à l'environnement
des ateliers sur la relation parents
enfants des ateliers sur la
communication non violente sur
l'éducation non violente sur les modes
de pédagogie alternative
et puis surtout le festival en fait on a
des animations enfants en agriculture on
a des animations sur les abeilles en
énergie il ya des aides des animations
sur la fabrication d'éoliennes
n on a en démocratie heures c'est un peu
moins pour les enfants mais les enfants
peuvent participer aussi sur la
rédaction d'articles cours de
constitution
voilà bientôt vous désertez on la disait
des thésards ayant accueilli évidemment
le conseil municipal des jeunes de la
ville de l'amérique
un petit mot aussi sur les bénévoles
moins qu'il ya deux cents bénévoles
mobilisés pour ces deux jours et pour
chercher encore du monde alors c'est
usant sont intéressés peuvent se bat
venir directement à la verrière pour
proposer leur service tout à fait au
dernier des eaux en été à 220 me nous
manque encore beaucoup de gens notamment
pour la restauration et donc s'il ya des
gens qui sont intéressés ou ce soir pour
finir d'installer les barnums et les
installations donc si les personnes qui
veulent vous n'avez pas y avoir du vent
et des orages mais a marre et après
demain il fera preuve il fera traiter
toujours est-ce que l'entrée du festival
est gratuite où il ya des animations qui
sont payantes
tout est gratuit tout est gratuit tout
est ouvert c'est un village on est au
coeur de la ville de la verrière est en
fait toutes les rues restent ouvertes
les gens peuvent accéder par là où ils
ont l'habitude d'accéder tout est ouvert
combien de temps pour mettre en place
tout ce festival parce que quand on
entend 220 bénévoles on se dit que c'est
beaucoup beaucoup de travail
et je vous remercie d'ailleurs d'être en
plateau avec vous ce soir parce que je
sais que vous êtes en train de monter
les équipements et que c'est pas simple
ça fait un an et demi en fait qu'on est
dessus alors pas plein temps mais ça
fait un an et demi qu'on y réfléchisse
et depuis deux trois mois ça s'est
intensifié ces dernières semaines c'est
beaucoup de gens à plein temps est ce
qu'il y aura une suite après alternatiba
de la verrière on sait que en septembre
y aura un internet ebay rambouillet y en
aura aussi bien dans le centre du des
yvelines toujours aussi au mois de
septembre
est ce que pour l'alternative à de la
verrière il est prévu une suite est ce
que prévu avoir un compte rendu ou
quelque chose oui on fera de toute façon
on est on pense à faire on va prendre
des images filmées
donc pour faire une suite pour pouvoir
documenter un petit peu cet événement et
il ya aussi une suite parce qu'on a le
tour tandem qui se lancent aussi
aujourd'hui à bayonne donc ça sera aussi
un tour qui va passer dans toutes les
villes de france pour promouvoir ces
alternatives positives donc ça c'est une
suite et puis la coordination européenne
alternatiba va chercher à donner une
deuxième vie à toute cette impulsion à
toute cette énergie citoyenne pour créer
des projets durables d'alternative
positif mais vous sur l'inde a demandé
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie de
participer à ce festival
le sais c'est pas une question piège
non quand anna c'est un sujet qui
m'intéresse ce sont le changement
climatique et les changements
environnementaux m'intéresse depuis très
longtemps et je trouve que c'est une
belle façon de prouver aux politiques
qu'on est impliqué qu'on réfléchit il ya
les scientifiques un travail beaucoup
sur les changements climatiques on a
d'ailleurs la l'avons conférence
scientifique qui se passe en juillet à
paris aussi donc où des scientifiques
parleront de l'évolution du climat
mais je pense que le citoyen aussi son
mot à dire et doit influencer
enfin merci beaucoup d'être venu sur le
plateau du studio et je vous laisse
repartir à la verrière pour continuer
les préparatifs merci ça c'est donc ce
samedi et dimanche à la verrière et tout
est gratuit
merci beaucoup aux interviews en plateau
ce jeudi la commune de plaisir a signé
un partenariat avec la ligue de
l'enseignement pour renouveler la
fonction d'un médiateur famille familles
principalement tournée vers le quartier
du vélib ou le médiateur fait le lien
entre familles enfants établissements
scolaires de la commune elle mélanie
poquet anna jimenez créer du lien entre
le scolaires et les familles expliquer
l'importance de l'école c'est le but du
médiateur famille le médiateur est
quelqu'un qui rapproche entre d'autres
personnes c'est quelqu'un qui est formé
pour la neutralité m passées à l'été et
l'écoutent
le médiateur est celui qui aide les gens
à trouver leur propre solution c'est pas
quelqu'un qui propose c'est pas
quelqu'un qui ont pour ma mission c'est
de rapprocher l'école et la famille
jette les parents comme jeudi avoir
acquis tour de l'école la plupart des
parents qui sont ici non pas la critique
de l'école c'est à dire l'accueil la
qualité de l'école modèles présents
depuis 2008 le médiateur travaille
principalement avec les familles du
vélib ou quartiers en réseau d'éducation
prioritaire
ça fait partie de notre politique de la
difficulté de ce quartier avec nos
différentes ethnies et qu'il est bien
pour la sociabilisation et l'intégration
nos enfants nous comme l'éducation
nationale ne pouvons pas rentrer dans
les familles
dire quand nous avons des enfants ou des
adolescents en difficulté ça permet si
je simplifiée de frapper à la porte des
familles et de pouvoir voir quelles
problématiques on pourrait résoudre
ensemble le secteur du médiateur
concerne trois écoles maternelles deux
élémentaire et le collège blaise pascal
et je vous propose maintenant un retour
sur l'actualité de la semaine écoulée
d'abord on va parler innovation une
plateforme technique ouverte à la
communauté scientifique mais aussi aux
entreprises une plateforme pour intégrer
et tester des équipements embarqués
elles des signes à étudier l'espace et
la terre la pit c'est son nom a été
inauguré jeudi dernier au sein de
l'observatoire de
versailles-saint-quentin basé à
guyancourt
visite guidée avec patrick jacques de
dixmude ce que vous voyez là est une
cuve à vide thermique pour les lots
missié cela ne veut pas dire grand chose
et pourtant dans cette cuve on peut
simuler à la fois les conditions d très
haute atmosphère
que ce soit au niveau spatial ou martien
un outil unique en france on peut
reconstituer quasi parfaitement
l'atmosphère qui règne sur mars et y
tester
les futurs instruments spatiaux qui
partiront sur mars il y en a très peu
dans le monde qui peuvent simuler
l'atmosphère martienne
un peu plus loin ce que l'on appelle un
pot vibrant qui lui sert à tester les
différentes parties des satellites pour
vérifier lors de leur lancement dans
l'espace qu'ils supporteront bien les
vibrations
actuellement l'on peut voir en est c'est
une antenne pour un radar martien ici
des bouées instrumenté qui seront
déployés dans l'océan arctique
dans le cadre de l'étude du changement
climatique 25 seront assemblées sur site
là encore une autre innovation un mur
d'image immersif ce mur sert
actuellement à faire de la modélisation
3d du tracking avec des données qui
viennent de différents laboratoires en
ce moment l'étude d'interaction des
vents solaires sur le champs électro
magnétiques terrestres l'aspect 3d et le
tracking ça permet de s'immerger
vraiment dans un modèle quand on a un
écran un petit écran de pc de bureau
vous même d'ordinateur on n'a pas la
notion vraiment
on n'a pas le rendu au temps de rendu
que dans le réel là on est vraiment
c'est comme si on se baladait dans
l'espace et qu'on peut plonger à
l'intérieur ça donne vraiment une
nouvelle vision de la chute de la
modélisation et ça permet d'en déduire
beaucoup plus de choses un mur
interactif dédié aux chercheurs n'est
pas seulement les entreprises peuvent
également l'utiliser
c'est le cas de cette start-up
saint-quentinoise qui utilisent le
mirent dans un but de mise en scène
immobilière
là on peut modifier les couleurs
le mur est à disposition de n'importe
qui qui aimerait vraiment évidemment la
principale ces scientifiques
ici on peut faire des partenariats avec
des start up ou des entreprises
on est on également porté à faire ce
genre de choses opéré une synergie entre
le monde scientifique et le monde
industriel une des possibilités de cette
plate forme d'intégration et de services
mise donc à la disposition de tous ça
permet non pas de faire de l'argent on
reste une plate forme académique mais ça
nous permet de limiter au mieux nos
coûts de fonctionnement qui sont
importants pour des infrastructures de
cette ampleur-là la plateforme aura
coûté 6 millions d'euros financés par
trois acteurs majeurs la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le cnes et le conseil régional
l'innovation toujours depuis janvier
2015 des élèves est courtois travail en
classe avec nao un petit robot humanoïde
une manière ludique pour faire découvrir
donc la robotique aux enfants tout en
travaillant de nombreuses notions
scolaire et plusieurs classes de
l'établissement de la commune se sont
rassemblés pour présenter leur travail
jean claude louis et estime qu est
excellente
difficile à croire mais cette
interaction ce sont les enfants eux
mêmes qu'ils ont créé cette classe de
cm2 de la commanderie travail avec now
depuis le mois de mars on va faire une
correspondance avec mal pour apprendre
l'anglais et on lan a fait un programme
mais sauf qu'on faisait parler now en
anglais ou en français les les deux à la
fois pour les gestes on a tous fait de
nous mêmes
avec un détail lines et pour le faire
bouger
nous-mêmes enfin pour par exemple levé
la main à droite cause naos et ce petit
robot humanoïde de 58 centimètres de
haut
développé par une société française
trois d'entre eux acheté par la commune
circule entre six groupes scolaires élan
courtois de la maternelle au lycée
près de 300 enfants sont concernés le
projet a été développé en partenariat
avec la direction académique numérique
et l'éducation nationale à travers piano
op le projet informatique dans les
écoles numériques dans les écoles pour
nous date depuis plus de dix ans est
donc l'aboutissement nous a semblé clair
il y a à peu près deux ans quand le
robot nao est sorti avec des
applications éducatif et ça nous a paru
évident de le mettre dans les écoles et
les collèges et les lycées du coup pour
permettre aux enfants d'acquérir les
compétences de codage informatique
on a voulu aussi donner envie aux
enfants de pouvoir avoir accès à ce
robot nao pour avoir plus d'enfants
qu'ils aient envie d'aller vers les
sections scientifiques côté notions
mathématiques programmation français
anglais mais pas seulement
ça leur a permis de vraiment de
comprendre que tout ce qui nous entoure
aujourd'hui ne fonctionnerait pas sans
la main de l'homme quand même puisque là
effectivement ils ont bien vu que pour
une seule
enfin une ou plusieurs questions ça leur
prenait quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
temps donc si on imagine pour tout ce
qui est autour de nous est effectivement
beaucoup de travail
j'aimerais encore un plus avoir de
choses parce que je comprends pas tout
est d'être dans le métier avec now on
peut aussi s'amuser
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il a l'oeil
voilà ça peut peut-être créer des
vocations jusqu'au 7 juin se déroule la
quinzaine régionale de la sécurité
routière à travers plusieurs opérations
la direction départementale de la
sécurité publique des yvelines
sensibilise à la protection des usagers
lundi un atelier sur la thématique
piéton est organisée à versailles de
l'aisne thérèse william elle en est sûre
le port vila sur le trottoir vous faites
des dérapages
vous traversez la bague les pieds sur le
presque sur le guide en tranquille pour
nous la sécurité vous mettez les autres
en danger non d'accord ce jour là sur la
place du marché de versailles
pas de sanction juste de la prévention
dans le cadre de la quinzaine de la
sécurité routière une opération de
sensibilisation était organisée hier
objectif repérer des piétons qui ont des
comportements dangereux dans les esprits
on va penser que le piéton est
prioritaire
malheureusement il faut bien comprendre
que dans le rapport trop puissant c'est
toujours le piéton qui va perdre
j'ai rarement vu un piéton s'en sortir
avec ce soit l'automobiliste qui soit
vraiment baissé sous le milliard en cas
de collision sur cette zone de sécurité
publique des yvelines
huit piétons ont trouvé la mort sur les
28 personnes tuées sur la route l'année
dernière c'est moins qu'en 2013 avec
eddy piétons sur 31 tués
il traverse à des endroits où ils ne
devraient pas ils sont distraits par
leur téléphone portable ou leur musique
dans les écouteurs les piétons ne sont
pas exempts des comportements à risque
il des problèmes d'alcool de stupéfiants
pourtant la seule sanction qu'un piéton
en cours est une amende de 4 euros
ça existe sachez le mais ça n'a pas
forcément une valeur suffisamment
pédagogique pour marquer les esprits du
piéton qui aura traversé là où il
n'aurait pas dû le faire se mettant
lui-même en danger et puis aussi
provocant un danger pour les autres
usagers de la route puisque on s'en
doute bien que quand on conduit soit son
véhicule soit sa moto de manière tout à
fait normale
qu'un piéton viennent se jeter sous vos
roues que vous veniez a percuté un
piéton que s'ils traversent n'importe où
c'est également extrêmement traumatisant
chapeau niveau de la bande mais la
demande est tellement minime pour les
piétons 4 euros risquent pas d'être
dissuasif par contre c 135 si on a
engagé pour la voiture si on n'en guérit
de passages piétons qu'ils respectent
pas mais bon il faut les arrêter fauqué
la police à ce moment là donc
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la
quinzaine de la sécurité routière ont
fait une opération alternative à la
sanction
je vous ai proposé ou des tranquilles et
devenir aussi recruté un petit port à
padirac
hier la direction départementale de la
sécurité publique
arrêter aussi les usagers de la route
aux comportements dangereux en 2015 dans
l'ensemble du département des yvelines
au 12 mai déjà 14 tués dont trois
piétons ce genre allez maintenant
terminé merci de votre attention retour
de l'information en direct lundi à 18
heures tout de suite vous avez rendez
votre le 7-8 week-end présenté par you
lie thorez je vous souhaite un excellent
week-end